اعلنت سلطنه عمان عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه بقوه
4.1 من عشره درجات على مقياس ريختر وفقا
لمركز رصد الزلزال او الزلازل في جامعه
السلطان قابوس فان الهزه سجلت في مدينه
الدقم على الساحل الجنوبيه الشرقي للسلطنه
وبين المركز ان الشعور بالهزه كان خفيفا
في الدقم وغير محسوس في المدن الاخرى بما
فيها العاصمه مسقط واشار المرصد الى ان
الشده الزلزاليه تختلف من موقع الى اخر
ومن مبنى الى اخر وفقا لارتفاعها وطبيعه
التربه
من مسقط ينضم الينا الدكتور عيسى الحسين
مدير مركز رصد الزلازل بجامعه السلطان
قابوس الدكتور عيسى مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض بدايه ما الذي رصدتموه
هذه الاجزال الارضيه في سلطنه عمان
المشاهدين طبعا حدث هزه ارضيه صباح اليوم
بالسبعه وخمسه وخمسين دقيقه
بمقدار
اربع واحد بالعشره بمقياس ريختار الزلازل
كانت على عمق 18 كيلو متر هذا العمق يعتبر
عميق الى حد ما حيث تبدل معظم الطاقه
تمتصه الارض ويصل من الاجهزه البسيطه على
على سطح الارض على شكل اجزاء
حدث في محافظه الوسطى وهي محافظه غير
مقبوله وهذا الزلزال من النوع الخفيف عاده
حتى لو شعر بها المواطنين وزلزال غير مؤثر
الا على بهالشكل محدود جدا على المباني
الطينيه او المتهالكه زلزال سجل لكن غير
غير مؤثر وبالتالي هذا يعني هذا المستوى
من الهزات الارضيه لا يوجد له هزات ربما
ارتداديه او تبعات خطيره دكتور
نعمل هزات الهزات معظم الهزات الارضيه
الكبيره او كل الهزات الارضيه الكبيره لها
توابع ذات الخفيفه مثل هذه نادر ما يكون
الا توابع واذا كان تكون خفيفه جدا جدا او
ضعيفه في مستوى لا يمكن الاحساس بها فقط
باجهزه الرصد الزلازل الحساسه جدا
الزلازل الخفيفه التوابع انها تتوقع ان
يحدث لها
طيب دكتور يعني علميا هل يمكن
يعني الربط بينما حدث في تركيا وسوريا
اتحدث هنا عن الربط يعني
المنطقه ككل بانها ربما تعيش مرحله من
مرحله الهزات او الزلازل او او ما الى ذلك
لانها لم تسجل الهزات فقط مثلا في في
سوريا وتركيا سجلت في دول اخرى ايضا في
محيطها
نعم هو احنا نتكلم عن الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه العربيه
مترابطه طبعا واللي ما حدث في الشمال
غرب الصفيحه العربيه في شمال شمال غرب
سوريا والجنوب شرق تركيا او جنوب تركيا هو
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من الصفيحه العربي
احنا بالجزائر الشرق
عاده البحوث العلميه تثير تشير الى بعض
الاحيان انه بعض الزلازل تحفز الزلازل
اخرى على صدور اخرى بس على الاغلب تكون
الصدوع قريبه منها يعني يسمونه
يعني انكسر
الضغوط خفت عليه صدى اخر مجاور او بالقرب
منه
ينشط زلزاليا اما بهذا البعد مسافه تقريبا
اكثر من 3000 كيلو تقريبا من
سبع شرق الاناضول
وسط المحافظه بعيد جدا لاحتمال مثل هذا
يعني حتى لو كان محفز يعني هو تحفيز بسيط
جدا يعني القوه الناتجه على التحفيز بهذا
المجال هي اجزاء بسيطه عشريه من البار
فتكون ضعيفه جدا طيب
يعني تاكيد علمي انه الزلازل تحرض بعضها
على الانتاجيه بس بعد المكاني بل بعد
الجغرافي نستبعد انه هذا التحريض من زلزال
تركي وبالتالي التحريض من الزلزال تركيا
ربما يكون يا دكتور للدول المعاديه او
القريبه مثلا من سوريا
يعني الطاقه الممتد من الخليج العقبه
المراغ بالبحر الميت الى الغاب بالسوريه
الى جنوب شرق تركيا لهذا يعتبر يعتبر خط
زلزال طويل جدا مشابه له في بين البحر
العربي والمحيط الهندي اللي امتد من
الصومال الى حدود الباكستان هذول الصدعين
هم يستاهلون انزلاق الصفيحه العربي باتجاه
الشرق والشمال الشرقي
اللي حدث عليه زلزال تركيا
يعني سبع شرق قال انا ظلم وامتداد جنوبا
الى خليج العقبه يعني ممكن يحفز زلازل في
لبنان في سوريا في فلسطين
وعاده تكون متتابعه وتكون زلازل صغيره
اغلبها تكون صغيره ممكن تكون محسوسه لكن
غير مؤثره الا على الاباني التي هي انهكت
وصارت يعني اصبحت متهلكه او انت تقصد يا
دكتور بانها غير محسوسه لان اليوم اداره
هيئه الكوارث التركيه مثلا اعلنت بان هناك
640 هزه ارتداديه سجلت بعد زلزال المدمر
والعنيف الذي ظرف السادس من فبراير
وبالتالي انا اساسا
ارتداديه دكتور هل هل تكون في محيط
من هذه المنطقه الجغرافيه
كل الزلازل الكبيره تحدث الا عندها
التوابع والتوابع احيانا تكون كبيره الى
حد ما وتكون مؤثره والكثير منها يكون
زلازل صغيره لانه الزلزال الضخم هو فرغ
معظم الطلب وكسر اكبر نتوء على سطح الفالق
اما النتوءات الاخرى على سطح الفالق
فتتالا بانكسارها
ممكن بعضها الاكبر وبعضها الاصغر وحجم هو
ينتج منها زلزال متوسط الى زلازل خفيفه
الاحساس بالزلزال لا يعني ان الزلزال مؤثر
يعني مرت من جنبنا شاحنه او قطار نشعر
باهتزاز المبنى فهذا اهتزاز
موكل زلزال تشعر به انه يعني يجب ان يكون
مؤثرا على المبنى يعني احنا نعيش في بيئه
والبيئه مترابطه
الاهتزاز احيانا يكون صحي لانه تنفس
الزلازلات
يعني تنتج الضغوط على الصدع بشكل جرعات
وتكون زلازل صغيره احسن ما تتجمع وتصير
اكبر دكتور انتم من خلال رصدكم يعني في
جامعه السلطان قابوس في رصد الزلازل
وبالنسبه لعمان او ايضا حتى دول
الخليج هل يعني تتوقعون او مثلا ترصدون او
تتنبؤون ايضا بالزلازل قبل ان تقع
بخطورتها ايضا كذلك نريد ان نفهم هذه
النقطه لانها مثار جدا للدكتور دائما انه
هل يمكن التنبؤ بالزلزال ام استحاله
التنبؤ فيه ايضا وفي نطاقه الجغرافي كذلك
وسائل جيد يطرح دائما هو التنبؤ بالزلزال
الى الان العلم لم يتوصل الى الى طريقه
علميه متسقه وموثقه تتنبا بالزلزال هناك
ظواهر قبل الزلزال العلماء عاده وصلوا الى
نوع من التوقع يتوقع النطاقات الزلزله
ويحددوا اكبر قدر زلزالي على كل نطاق
زلزالي اما التنبؤ بالزمان هذا اللي الى
الان استحاله تحديد
يكون التنبؤ مفيد الي والك صدر المشاهدين
والمهندسين لازم يتوفر في عناصر الوقت وهو
لازم كل هذا الوقت حتى يكون مفيد
والمكان والقوه واحتماليه وقوع هذا الزفاف
اذا ما توفرت كل هذه العناصر واهمها الوقت
يبقى
نسميه توقع او فوركاس فقط اشكرك جزيل
الشكر والمسقط انضمي لان الدكتور عيسى
الحسين مدير مركز رصد الزلازل بجامعه
السلطان قابوش بقابوس